this brian stelter guy you know you know
my feelings on this guys 50 50 whether
we have to talk about these people
anymore or not it's totally 50 50. i
i've discussed it with many people
do we just start ignoring these
ridiculous clowns who all the way by the
way
i know that they watch this show like i
know that plenty of producers
at cnn and a bunch of the other uh
channels watch this show because i'm not
stupid and i have insiders a lot of
these people and
a lot of these places and a lot of the
people that work for you guys don't like
you guys
because you're all frauds and liars well
brian stelter he's got this show
reliable sources it should be unreliable
sources you know all that stuff
and all he does all day long is
basically
watch fox news to try to figure out a
way to take down
fox news that's what cable news has
reduced itself to
um so here's a video of brian stelter
yesterday
ironically accusing hannity fox
and the right-wing scary people of
conspiracy conspiracies
and inflammatory language take a look to
understand why so many republicans have
abandoned democracy
to see why so many believe the big lie
to get why so many are trying to rewrite
voting rules
you have to hear the poisonous
propaganda that the gop's activist base
is listening to
you have to really hear it it's coming
more from sean hannity than from trump
right now
so that's what we did this week we
watched every episode of sean hannity's
show
and we color coded it as you can see we
focus on his language the insults and
phrases that he repeats every night
biden's a weak frail cognitive mess
hannity says yet the democratic party is
portrayed as an existential threat
hannity calls it the new green deal
socialist party and he labels some dems
extremists he calls american cities hell
holes
sometimes he calls them democratic run
hellholes and he says the media is a mob
full of quote stalkers don't get numb to
this abusive language
because it is through these insults it
is through these attacks
that hannity wields power this dark dire
language is fundamentally authoritarian
hannity is spouting poison
i literally just cracked up throughout
that even though i've seen it like 10
times this morning
first off pretty much everything hannity
said is right they are democratic
hellholes right
they are everything everything he says
he said the republicans the base they're
trying to rewrite the voting rules well
of course
stelter never explains to you what it is
that these gop
bills are trying to do like you know
have people use ids
to vote as i talked about last week i
went mini golfing
and to actually get the small golf club
i had to show
an id and they actually held it for us
these are not
crazy things but i love that stelter had
his people watch
all of the show and they had color
coding
people are watching this and they are
being br like that's the reverse
of the truth that man's job is to
reverse the truth so i guess it does
make sense that his show reliable
sources
is named backwards and it should be
unreliable sources like it's just
absolutely extraordinary and also the
way he's seating it that it's somehow
it's somehow those right-wingers who
don't believe
are nonsense that are being violent and
hannity's using inflammatory language to
rile people up
and it's like no man it's your base
burning down cities it's your base
looting and destroying windows and yes
they are in democratic hell holes
it's not happening in republican cities
so the question is
as always and i'm i'm as i said i'm 50
50 on this and i would love more
feedback so maybe this will be the
discussion of the day
in uh in the locals community is do we
have to
keep talking about those people to
expose them like that man and acosta
and that ridiculous larping lunatic
chris cuomo
and everyone at cnn they are actors
pretending to be journalists that's what
they are i'm not a journalist
i'm a guy who sits here i tell you what
i think you can call me what you want
but i don't pretend i'm anything other
than what i am okay
i am what i am and that's all that i am
i'm pop by the sailor man there you go
guys okay we're gonna have a little
spinach after the show today
but the point is these people they are
lying to all
of these people and then you wonder why
people are insane you wonder why karen's
are screaming at people and people are
angry
and fighting with people and and wearing
masks until they're
until they're 90 and dead and it's just
like it's just like
get control of your life that's my
message dave rubin at 45
get control of your life find happiness
find friends find good people eat good
food
do what you like do it and don't listen
to brian stelter how much more do you
need people